yeah um i guess two questions
um how did how did you as guys as a team
what led you guys kind of
to reach the position you're at
wednesday night in terms of
deciding not to not wanting to play and
then
what discussions were happening for the
next 12 hours
um to lead the team to say you know what
let's let's play
and then also with you what transpired
for you before i get to forget i think
collectively as a
as a team i just wanted to stay united
with every other team
here in the bubble and uh of course the
dialogue that we had
you know was uh between players players
only but
whatever dialogue that was it it came
out to be positive
you know anything with communication
um good communication bad communication
uh emotional communication um any type
of communication leads to answers and uh
and we've been fortunate to uh have a
good pa we've been fortunate to have a
um a great nba
foundation that you know we were able to
take care of our families and
communication was good and it led to uh
you know some action
and that's the most important thing
andrew did you have a second question i
i guess pat i guess
would you care to address kind of what
transpired um
between yourself and michelle roberts
there's obviously that was a topic
oh um oh just you know we had uh
we had a very interesting um
conversation the pa is like a family i'm
pretty sure everyone here and all the
cameras pointing to me hey everyone's
a part of a family you don't always
agree with your family members and
that's okay
you communicate about it and you you try
to make it better
and whatever the dialogue was or
whatever you guys think it is
we made things better yesterday meeting
with the owners and that's the most
important
thanks andrew holm go ahead
hey pat um there were reports that you
guys the clippers and the lakers were
ready to
in in the initial polling we're ready to
not continue with the season
and then yesterday obviously everybody
agreed to play what
what are the last like 24 48 hours been
like as far as the emotions for you guys
as a team
were you guys ready to kind of continue
and not play championship mindset
here ready to get you know i'm done
talking to you good people
we head in practice and try to compete
and try to get ready for the dallas
mavericks
thanks om uh next up is miriam go ahead
miriam
hey there pat good to see you man um
good to see you good to talk to you too
man hey so uh the nba and the pa put out
a statement this morning kind of with
detailing some of the social justice
initiatives and and
you know that that they're gonna make
arenas polling places and things like
that
have you seen that i mean that's just
come from communication it's hard kind
of get you know
uh so many nba guys in one room together
um
i think it was a funny analogy like man
you probably have some of the
you know wealthiest african-americans in
one room um
in the country together and uh you know
when you get in one room and you get to
the top you know
just like you know you believe in
certain things i might not believe in
and vice versa anyone here
and there's good dialogue good
conversations with which led to uh
action and we were able to get that
action i think doc was there
um kind of um leading the forefront of
that and
we're excited we're excited to stay here
we're excited to be here
and we're excited to not only uh compete
but be pioneering
in today's and today's change within the
world
uh brad turner from the la times go
ahead brad
thanks chris pat how are you doing today
man
the question is when all of you
predominantly african-american males
have a conversation with predominantly
wealthy billionaires that are white i
don't know you guys
i one part i wanted in that conversation
so i i don't even know how to answer
oh but on a daily basis
[Laughter]
i know what you're saying because i i
talked to improvising myself
but when you guys finally hear what the
plan is
is there's some satisfaction that
they're hearing your voices
and you hope they take that back to
their contingencies and people that they
have power with
yeah i think everybody's just trying to
you know help that's it and uh
everyone's just trying to help the cause
and i'm trying to get a positive change
out of this
i think that's the uh i think that's the
message that's been a message that's
been the only message
good what's up baby how are you all
right good baby good to see you again
[Music]
thank you no problem good to talk to you
too you too
thanks bt hi hey pat we're gonna take a
question from mark medina there in
orlando with you
okay yes yeah to your point about steve
ballmer what has been your takeaway is
on
on his level i mean i mean it goes
without saying
i mean you see it like that's something
we don't have to talk about you see it
and you feel it
i mean that speaks that speaks for
itself
uh next question pat's gonna come from
taylor rooks go ahead taylor
so is there optimism around change
happening like what is success going to
look like for you after this
kind of situation right now uh i mean i
don't understand the question
like what will success look like what
will have to happen from the
conversations you guys have had as
players oh i mean i think
everything like that takes time uh but
you know
our platform is here and just to use
that platform to
you know inspire motivate give knowledge
uh listen you know whatever the case may
be and uh
and you know when you get out of here
just continue to keep that same attitude
take it to your communities take it to
your
when you play at it you know it's all
step by step to try to do better and
better as well
uh next question pat is coming from far
by go ahead for our body
hey pat hope you're doing well uh one of
the big things we saw was doc rivers was
kind of the voice of everything that's
been happening the last couple days you
know his speeches went viral
how proud were you to have him as a
coach in that moment
especially him being from chicago so i
kind of understand his lingo more
more than kind of anybody here but you
know doc you know he's
he's he's helped us you know not only
you know as a coach
what's up he's helped us uh kind of kind
of steer things in the right direction
that we need to steer
to and he has knowledge uh he's been
around
you know he has a lot of connections he
has a lot of access to
you know to doors that you know neither
anybody else might not have
access to he's able to put out in words
you know that you know i'm me as an
athlete that i might not be able to put
out
he's able to put those words out and and
and delay a message
and and not only to get through the
african-american community that gets
through to everybody so
i mean to you know [ __ ] that not even a
coach to even have a person like that
to even have a person like that that's
in your corner that's riding for you
that
[ __ ] put the ball in your hands you know
like to even have a person like that
it's a great deal of respect annie from
you know from the creative too so
you know it's uh it's it's respected and
this is it's all love there you know
great thank you pat have a good practice
oh man that was